the government shutdown I do got to
bring up some negative news it's in its
34th day that's the longest in US
history and one of the agencies hit
hardest during this shutdown is the
National Park Service that's too bad
yeah without employees our national
parks are getting neglected and sadly I
hate to bring it up but so are one of
our parks most important inhabitants I'm
talking of course about their overfed
squirrels they're really yeah yeah those
fat squirrels are being neglected I
decided to use this show for good so I
decided to help out by creating a
Wildlife Refuge for our national parks
beloved obese squirrels they're right
here
[Applause]
these overweight squirrels will be cared
for and fed to die and they're
accustomed to diet like leftover pizza
Doritos and of course discarded juice
boxes
squirrels are adapting well they seem
happy in their new hot wait and wait
something's going on middle verse little
squirt is having a heart attack
ladies and gentlemen middle school is
having a heart attack this is really bad
I know this is really bad to make
matters worse I think the other
squirrels are getting ready to eat their
dead friend one of them has got hot
sauce and he's applying it to the dying
squirrel can someone help please welcome
an obese owl is coming with
defibrillator paddles he is landing and
he is gonna bring it from the puppeteer
is good enough yes he's one more hit
should do it I don't know where he's
landing it doesn't seem to matter is it
and he's no pay the obese girls